a lot of people have been asking me
about the shot the other night Michael
in traffic to turn and there have been
some misconceptions about what actually
happened I wanted to clear it up when we
called time out with 25 seconds to go
we went into the Huddle
he comes off I'll be ready
little Charles Michael he said Michael I
want you to take the last shot
and Michael said you know Phil I don't
feel real comfortable in these
situations
so maybe we ought to go in another
Direction
why don't we go to Steve
so I thought to myself well I guess I
gotta bail Mike Rod again
here's Jordan
did not have the shot
the shot went in and that's my story and
I'm sticking to it
hahaha